le tueur à coincer ces trois victimes
dans la basilique notre dame de
l'assomption
une homme de 60 ans a été décapitée le
sacristain un homme de 55 ans père de
deux enfants a été poignardé à mort une
femme de 30 ans qui avait réussi à
échapper on a trié a succombé à ses
blessures dans un bar tu crées où elle
s'était réfugiée arrivé précipitamment
emmanuel macron est d'abord allé se
recueillir sur les lieux du crime puis
il s'est adressé aux français
simplement de dire notre détermination
absolue et que des actes continuerons de
suivre pour protéger tous nos
concitoyens pour répliquer
c'est donc un message de fermeté absolue
que je veux passer aujourd'hui emmanuel
macron présidera demain conseil de
défense pour faire le point sur cette
crise
l'agresseur est un tunisien de 21 ans
prénommé brahim il invoquer allah au
moment des faits mais aussi après coup
devant le personnel médical ébranlé le
maire de nice a déploré que sa ville
soit encore une fois ciblée par le
terrorisme
l'auteur de ces actes qui n'a cessé de
répéter en boucle devant nous la wac
barre alors qu'il été médicalisé sur
place
quel était le sens de son geste
sous le choc ses paroissiennes amis du
sacristain se sont effondrés en armes
outre sa crise depuis cinq minutes c'est
bien on est tous révoltés ce niçois
refuse de se laisser abattre
il y à un une tentative de mettre la
france en otage et de la prendre en
otage par rapport à ces musulmans nous
ne retomberont pas dans ce piège là
peu après l'attaqué de nice un homme
armé d'un couteau a été arrêté à avignon
puis à lyon un afghan déjà dans la mire
des services de renseignements a été
appréhendé il avait sur lui un couteau
de 30 cm et un employé du consulat
français à djeddah en arabie saoudite a
survécu à une attaque à l'armé blanche
ici nathalie cloutier radio canada
montréal